if we really want to convert germany
to complete climate neutrality within a few years
then
it will be really difficult what i
hear is also a complete
social 40 so in the end
climate protection itself is simple
human protection is overslept
was overslept we have to
look ahead i will  not all the solutions
to one of the greatest crises of mankind
have to offer here and
fortunately there are a lot of people sitting here
and their job that is
but the juso politicians directly in front of the
toni toni monteure election.de
split-screen mode
ruby ​​something center and politicians want
first  and topix shaping the election
of germany's climate policy
scottish singer
i'm from berlin i think now is
the time for radical climate protection
we have to take precautions so that the
climate crisis doesn't turn into a catastrophe for more and more
people now is our
last chance my name is
sebastian  lachman and ic  h am of the
opinion that we must maintain economic
strength and the standard of living in
germany in the fight against
climate change
yes or no are you afraid of
because i am convinced that we in
germany are well positioned
to counteract climate change and
i am not of mine  natural from the
anxious type
yes i think it's different for
me i think the climate crisis what what i
believe in many places which
you can't even imagine i
think with what has happened recently
maybe more so i
think i'll come  from nrw and
have just seen talking to so many
people who have been hit really dramatically in a
way that i don't think
i can put into words before and even now
[music]
you know how it affects  you
personally the climate change at the moment
i don't notice
the weather where i
come from  Lusatia has been very dry ever since
I was a child
[music]
we always have to struggle with some kind of
water shortage
but I don’t really know that any other way,
on the other hand
I know what happened so badly in North Rhine-Westphalia
my personal
childhood with the elbe flood there was
that too the question is were we
properly prepared for it
and that with climate change it will
come anyway the climate will
change the question is how
severe
my question is when you get into
the other  situation shifted in the
climate movement we have few
coal miners running there he gives
one in the bigger skepticism and when i
am in lausitz i hear in the
skepticism about climate protection with many
coal come further about the work
you can tell in each case how
can you convince the other side
that is better he can with more
climate protection and what would have to happen for that
so it's not that
any of the coal miners are
n't convinced or aren't convinced
that climate change exists
or that their job
is in danger because of the climate because of
climate policy, but the
way we go about it, how we do it,
is the question  the right one we
want to get 38 out of the coals first there was a
long, long fight for this compromise
then it was said that 35 would be better okay
now we're at 30 at some point
we'll maybe be at 25 there was a
general
consensus that we've been fighting for this paper for more than twelve months
to get and that's going
to be swallowed up completely before the election
[music]
even if I take 38 as a coal exit
, there isn't much time left to
build something new there, to achieve change in
the companies, it's
not just about  the mining companies or
the
power plant operators, it's also about
suppliers, it's about
metal-producing trades, service partners,
yes, you too  e have to
reorient themselves that does
n’t happen overnight and you have to
say that very clearly i haven’t been involved with the
topic for a while now in
the wind and solar industry not
so many jobs are needed in the
when the systems are in the  i
think that in the end there will
be a lot somewhere and because in the end we just want to
continue to lead a good life
and the people who are currently
threatened that their jobs might be eliminated
that the jobs will change massively
i think they will have the same one somewhere
say it existential fear so what
happens to me like me or like a
lot of people from my generation have
a really big concern about what
happens how will my
future develop how safe it is at all in
life that is somehow waiting for me
and that’s why i think  that there can
actually be a lot of understanding for each other
and we don't personally think
we have to sc
hnell out of the coal because that is otherwise the
basis for the mission to
emit and coal phase-out by
20.30 is actually something for me now
if we look at it scientifically,
which is no longer
negotiable and at the same time it is of
course still clear it can  yes, it is not
possible that 10,000 people will just
get upset
[music] in
the end it will not just be that
the weather will change, but that
will have effects that will also spill over into
society and if I
then imagine a combination of
this scarcity of resources the
worldwide migration is increasing because
people simply can no longer stay at home
a right-wing pressure that
we are already aware of now so i
'm also just worried about
political and social
conflicts in my future service that will
still come yes i
don't think I can follow that there  the thoughts but I also
think we are here in  germany
has already gotten through a few crises
and mostly stronger than before and that's
why i also think that we also have
to do something to counter climate
change but you said that
correctly it's a global issue
that means we germany in germany
alone while that doesn't
matter  we need all the other
countries on earth and they all have to
pull together we are in a
situation where i have very
little time and it looks
very very bad in many places,
also from a german
perspective and in the end it will  it
must be the case that we have to be climate-neutral all over the world,
i.e.
emissions everywhere have to go down to zero
and then that means of course
we also have to go down to zero in Germany,
then you can always
say that the others have to do it
too and  That's right, you're right,
but we have to do it first
o i found it very interesting that you
both said yes, we have to
tackle the whole thing internationally because
only if we
achieve the climate protection goals in germany will
climate change not be
stopped and i would definitely go along
with it and say that is exactly it
the right approach because in
the end i think going it alone
would actually cause more damage because other
countries wouldn't pull along that's why
i would take that back with me as an
important point would you
say that germany should lead the world
in climate policy
i have the feeling we should too  so
totally dishonest when we look at
how big historical emissions of our
country are and then 40 and even
show them how to save everything here now
but of course it is so
i think germany has to be a
country and above all it
can be what is now  really big strides
ahead and if we are the first
you  e open new markets, so to speak, if
we are the ones where technologies are
developed if we are the ones who
can now serve as a role model for
how do we really manage to switch from one year
to a completely
climate-neutral fossil systems in germany it is
difficult to say now germany
should the world  Leading I think
we can play a role in
developing technologies that
can possibly help countries that
are not so economically
positioned right now, but I don't
think we are currently a nation that
is the pioneer here in
technology, so we're not
really getting there  from the spot and from my point of view
much more must therefore be
invested in research development
open to technology yes not the electric vehicle is the future not
the wind turbine and the solar system we
have to think ahead invest in all directions
and see which solutions
or which mix we will find in the future
the security of supply gives the comfort
that we currently have the standard of living that we currently have
with less co2 emissions or
none at all so i think you have to
be honest if
we want to do it if we really want to convert
germany to complete climate neutrality within a few years
then we will  it's really difficult
and it's going to be an insane
challenge, politically,
socially, maybe at
first economically, but the
costs of not doing it on
all levels are just so
incredibly high that we ca
n't afford it, i don't think, and then you
have to  let’s also see if science
is saying we no longer have the
time to go into all areas of the
rhine that are open to technology because
otherwise we would just miss our chances
because the time windows are
closing to really get to 1 15
degrees, then in my opinion
that’s it  moment  where you also have to say we
have to do everything we can now
to stop this catastrophe
[music]
and right now, so to speak, with
what we have just seen in North Rhine-Westphalia,
I believe
that it's just damage, the costs
if  I think it's estimated at two
billion
euros that happened within k hours
existences that were completely
lost so many people who had to
die through such a flood
through such a flood I think these are
things that we can't afford
and they want  we can't
afford it either
and i think it just has to have
priority and i just find
all this beating about it always
this there are so many different
options
that's just so dishonest what
i hear is also a complete social renunciation here
because  we don't now tread the path
as we would currently go
, that means for me
in the future we will
probably not be able to
satisfy the ones we are currently satisfying i
do
n't think that's even short-lived if you
say we're going with the way now
we have to go faster and
we can no longer
look at the other alternatives we're missing them  time that
would now mean we go with the
energy mix we are now looking at is
co2 neutral, i.e. no coal nuclear power
no longer wanted no
gas power plants because are co2 emitters
and even with all emitters so it
doesn’t work then we’ll stay
somewhere with niche products like
biomass like
hydropower  which we
really don't have much in germany and then we have
solar and renewable i
deliberately looked this morning at what
electricity production looks like in germany
and more than half came from
conventional generation where do we get
that from if we don't cut
corners because that means  then that as soon as
the sun and no longer sc  heint and
the wind is blowing more that means it can be
happy when everyone has to drive to work it
can be in the evening when everyone is at
home what do I do then that means
I have to go without I ca
n’t even turn on the light I can’t watch
tv I can’t  cooking except
i might have a storage tank so that
the so and creates itself now but
actually we would have if
we had put everything differently over the last few
decades we could
already be at 100 percent
renewable energies and i think
it is the case  the security of supply
in germany is not acutely
endangered it is now above all
i think it is important that
you can see the problem is not only
how do we get out of fossil
energies and then how do we get into
renewable energies and we can see exactly
the same thing that
happens too little politically and in many countries
that or so states that they are
also active  slowed down is
sebastian you can come from a region that
is very affected yes now by this
structural change and my question would be first of
all you that would
you wish for locally so if the goal
of climate neutrality is shared what
perspectives does it need locally what
then it has to happen on site in order to
take the people there with you and
then the question for you do you
actually have ideas and concepts at
freddie for future so i
think and i hope it's okay if
i say that too i'm 19 years old at the end of the day
old did my high school diploma last year
and i don't think i will have
all the solutions to one of the greatest
crises of mankind right now
and luckily there are a
lot of people here and their job is
to somehow find a police officer and
i think you have to  also say
that i can't do that i
can't present the concepts for
how we ultimately ensure that
we  t society in such a large
economy is completely
turned inside out yes so the first
clear answer is you
should stick to what you have
decided at the political level yes that is the first
point of reliability in order to also
have plannable sizes if we now
change the topic every week  discuss how
quickly the structural change
should be completed then we won't be able to do it
and the time is already short
to achieve structural change there in the years to come
settling the industry doesn’t really matter from which direction it
comes first i
have to intervene again very briefly
because you said in the end
climate protection will above all
mean restrictions and waivers
because i believe that in the end it’s exactly the
other way around, so this is the
social  discourse always very often
to we may now  don't do something too
fast it shouldn't all change now it should
change worse i think in the
end it's exactly the
opposite so we're
doing climate protection right now to
take preventive care
to make sure that i end up  not
everything has changed, but we can still have
a good life and that is
exactly why it is so
essential that we tackle things now
in order to then ensure that we live
as quickly as possible in the
economy where all jobs are sustainable, where
all jobs ensure that  At the end of the day, we do
n't continue to exploit the environment and human beings, we do
n't continue to contribute to the destruction,
but also live in the economic
system, which in itself simply
ensures that people can do well.
Sebastian, you were very optimistic at the beginning
, as I said, that we can
cope with the current climate
politics that somehow deal with
climate change and the optimism is missing  yes
obviously when it comes
to accelerating the energy transition what
would interest me where is the greatest lack of
optimism where do you see the biggest construction
site is it technologically up-to-
date it is that people
may have to do without comfort
adapt their behavior or
where i see them  biggest construction site how it
would be organized so first division
always give and take we won't
find the solution for everyone and everyone
is happy with it and that's why i say
you have to be honest and tell people
that one thing it costs
a lot it will be a lot  cost a lot and
you have to go without it, otherwise it wo
n't work, I'm not so
optimistic that without doing without,
not the way we're describing the way now
, so I think I would
agree with you and I've
honestly said that, it will be a
challenge  and things won't
stay the way they are but
changes will ha  lt come one way
or another and we can make a decision right now
, we
will experience massive changes because
we just don't contain the climate crisis and
i have the feeling that sometimes
people feel like this
isn't even a scripture but when
you  looks at what will the climate crisis mean in
germany is it just so
massive
i.e. health risks that will increase to such an extent where heat waves will claim
thousands of lives among old sick
people these are all changes that
will come or we decide
now to organize and regulate them and to
tackle a change together  which in
the end ensures that these
catastrophic conditions will not
occur is
right that we can only achieve climate change
if we all together
as many of us as possible are at least
convinced
that we are going in the same direction and i believe that we have a
positive image of the  future
we will need d  we can't do it
if we only pray about
renunciation, what about a positive image that has a
different view of needs, for example
, i would be interested in what are your positive images of a climate-friendly, sustainable society, so i
think if we do it well then
we'll live  In the end, not only in a
climate-neutral world, but in the
end we also live in a fairer and
better one because I believe it is like that, so
if you change a lot, there are of
course a lot of
opportunities and I believe that there is also
something that you can do
must focus more on where there are definitely a
lot of different views
, so to speak, what should that
look like what kind of society
do we want to live at all
?
I consume so I'll say it like that of
this vision of the future  I'll
say that now that's bad yes well the
beautifully painted I think it's great I would sign it like
that if something like that happens but
ultimately there is a way
to get there and it has to be walked
and it will also hurt
and for me that's the  reality and that's not
what I'm concerned about in the end, of course, we
need a goal and we need a
political goal, yes, we need
a Vision 2050 for all sectors, how
do we get there, but not the way things are
currently going, then you also have to
tell the citizens  say that fuel and that
has now been done more and more, that it is becoming more
expensive, that electricity is becoming more expensive, that
the quality of life has to
be reduced somewhat, perhaps even
drastically, in order to get there
, and if everyone then wants it and
everyone agrees, then that will also be the
case  find social consensus
you can now decide in
politics whether you go one way
by looking at a lot of individual details
so regulation is very
technology-based, politically dictates
what you want to do and then, above all,
does not regulate the co2 or
greenhouse gases, but above all
then sees which technology is
right or I look for other
ways and say okay, something like a co2 limit or
a  hard CO2 cover one that has to drop, so to speak
, and which I also
ban the emission of. I would be
interested to know where would you say it
makes sense to regulate the gases specifically
or to go into the details of the
individual technologies, so I
think the second thing you
we have now addressed something like
emissions trading
[music]
so i think time is running out that
we probably have to try everything
first i
would say and that is emissions trading
which is really important but we
won't either  get around it to price
co2 unbelievably high so to
say there is another medium  to
choose and thus show that there is a rough
framework for it, that in the
end it is no longer worthwhile to emit more
greenhouse gases, but that it
is economically worthwhile to
tackle changes and at the same time
and that is what i have said i
have said before in some areas
we have  just slept too long and
we don't have the time to
just
sound out all the avenues again or
to sniff out every corner I think
is open to technology. for me it
's an important component to
remain open to technology because we
don't want to  sticking to the status quo
so
, in my view, just relying on solar and wind is
not the way that will bring us all a
happy future we
have to remain open to technologies we also have to
remain open to technology when it
comes to drives for vehicles  work in a mix
and for me that is always the
point be  i you guys at free for future yes the
back is history we ca
n't change it
we've overslept we have overslept we have to
look ahead and now to look ahead
and to say there is only this one
way is exactly the mistake we made in the
last  make time more often regardless of whether there is a
pandemic or not we have to
take everyone with us again all
scientists listen to all opinions and not only the ones i want to
hear right now what suits me in stuff
yes but also the other side
higher do you think because freely this
decreed is also in the requirements  a
bit naive i think your naivety
is the big driver of your action
so that's actually yes
yes tell me a figurehead that
you just approach it so naively you
don't think about what the father of a
family who somewhere has to support his
family in the first
stepney  you think of the big picture with
your naivety he presses his finger in the
wound it has an animal
Get n drive politically,
socially, economically,
but in the end you have to
stay objective again and see what works,
what doesn't work, weigh up what is the best
alternative, in order to then also maintain
our business
location and our standard of living to a certain
extent because we as human beings are
always  out to improve and not
to make anything worse than it is right
now so i
called gretchen in again very briefly i have
the feeling it sounds as if the case
is in the end a group of young
people and they think up something like
you  would like to have your future so the
basis of it is that we refer to
exactly what the best
science says about the climate and
that is all that we refer to
i never thought of
it in any way yes i would like it like that now
it would be so nice if the economy
looked like this, that's not the
approach we used to do it  ns
and i don’t think we
can be accused of that we are
not concerned with how people are doing in
the end i.e. at the end of
climate protection itself it’s also simply
human protection that always sounds a bit
abstract but let’s give an example
maybe to justify that what we
here builders in wind turbines
the vehicles with batteries that does
not come from the coal mine in Lusatia
yes where working conditions where there is a works council
where there are occupational health and safety
conditions that have been written down over centuries
and have
solidified they are in
dismantled in countries where people don't even have an
occupational safety shura yes and that for
our climate protection so that we
feel comfortable so if there I have to rewrite the whole
picture and not everything stop
supply chain laws so there has
to be political
solutions for that too so I don't know I  but
that is yes that is a difficult topic
a final question for you b  eide
, if you have now learned something from the
discussion about women with him,
what would that be? i think
such conversations are just super
rare and i'm often
somehow in my own little bubble
and i think that's really
important is there  this to stay in the conversation
and i think like you said
we have to admit it will be
exhausting and we will
probably have to
argue often that we are there in the end
but i firmly believe that we
can find the way how we can do it
together in the end  bring and in the end still
make sure that you still have
a good job in 20 years so from my point of
view it is that we as a society have to work
together so that we are
not opponents or black and white
but we are a lot of people with
different opinions on
different points  but exactly
such discussions are necessary in order to face
the future together
its good is in  principle in germany
these two camps you can feel it
somehow on the one hand the young
people who keep
shouting that the chinese climate crisis is what to do and the
others are on the brakes not
necessarily because they want to unite the climate crisis
but they say the thing is more complex
when the now in your in their slogans
on the street maybe you
should have a very exciting discussion
i was surprised again how well
prepared you know for example many
who are politically
active don't deal with
individual issues as intensively as her and also that he
the solution approaches so the successor
has not been very
exciting i actually found it exciting when asked whether
germany should be a pioneer that
both the police and sebastian
wait a bit uncertainly over the years
agreed so they noticed very clearly
both pauline and
sebastian ring a lot about it  how to
react to this climate change and s
they were really in exchange with each other
so it's not against each other how
the two just discussed
describes itself now the debate is going on
nationwide there is the
opposite open either we do
radical climate protection either protect
the climate or we protect the
employees and team one of the
two  or one only half and that
's actually not true because the
task of politics is to say
that both are fully implemented and the
two and what you did well that
both of them actually couldn't put themselves in the box
didn't put me in the box afterwards has no
contacts  i also knew that in areas
i had no idea or i
knew it had to drive on the other
side this was very exciting as you saw
with felder futures that
is actually often about
writing a little problem and that because the
expectations of politics are here
listened today that the solution will be
delivered and these are  an
incredible speed if you look
at the democratic processes
you can see that it often takes a little
longer to give up this conflict
in which one tends to focus more on the
faction level oakley drivers for me today
are actually the most exciting thing
but it is actually the case that germany is often a
pioneer in many things  is
in connection with the european
union
and we are not only the largest country, so to speak,
and are located in the middle of europe,
but the whole of europe often
looks at us germany and sees how we
solve problems and in this respect it is very
important that we participate in many  places
go ahead and also here on the subject of
environmental protection and in general
i find it very exciting in the
discussion that is that with the change of
sides it just worked very well
we really just
turned it around and the citizens
were the focus and not  the
politicians just listened they
have  en asked questions and I think this
is really an approach with a lot of future
you can do that more often as
a politician you definitely take a lot
with
thank you so much for watching the apps
or fingers gruber developing the
format ulrike you asked to participate
in the  discussion on the whole league